At this point, virtually nobody on Earth scratches
their heads and wonders how it is that wealthy
actors tend to look so fit and healthy. The answer
is simple: They have teams for that, and more
often than not, they're in tip-top shape because
they're being paid to do so. When it's time to get
absolutely shredded for their latest action movie,
actors assemble their fitness Avengers: exercises
coaches, nutritionists, stuntmen with years of
experience, professional mixed martial artists,
and anyone else who might be able to take an
already in-shape body to the superhuman level.
There are very few actors out there
as ripped as Chris Hemsworth is,
which makes sense considering who
he plays in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe. It's one thing to be a
super-soldier like Steve Rogers…
“As far as I’m concerned, that is America’s ass.”
or an intergalactic guardian like Peter
Quill, but it's quite another to be Thor,
the Asgardian god of thunder. And while Thor was
in a very different kind of shape by Avengers:
Endgame, looking rounder around
the middle and longer in the beard,
Hemsworth in real life tends
to keep himself pretty jacked.
“Strongest Avenger.”
“Access denied.”
“STRONGEST AVENGER.”
Recently, Hemsworth decided to get
into the app business and create Centr,
a pay-to-use app that makes his team
of fitness professionals your team
too, with customized meal plans and workout
regimens to help you reach your health goals.
And what better way to promote Centr than to
post a hilarious ad that blends Hemsworth's
unfiltered Aussie humor with his dedication
to fitness and his personal team's expertise?
"And allow my soothing baritones
to wash over you. I love you."
Hemsworth took to Instagram on March 23rd to share
the ad with his 47 million-plus
followers. It features a number
of people working out ... who all just so
happen to be the actor himself — sort of.
In the video, Hemsworth's head appears over the
bodies of a number of people, most of whom are
dedicating themselves towards some kind of
physical or mental wellness — working out,
doing yoga, meditating, and so on... Hemsworth
speaks all the dialogue, discussing in very
colorful terms how unlikable he is and how awesome
the people who work with him are. In Hemsworth's
words, he's a "f-----g d--k" and his team is
"f-----g brilliant." Two women — who, again,
both have Hemsworth's face — discuss how they
prefer Chris' brother Luke, for example, and a
guy cooking things up on the grill confesses he'd
rip off Chris Hemsworth's face in a cage match.
Those who've kept up with Hemsworth's
personal and professional endeavors
will recognize this new clip as an uncensored
version of a Centr ad that ran in February.
It's the same premise — Hemsworth's head
superimposed over other people's bodies,
him saying that working out with his
team is basically like working out with
him — but with updated dialogue not fit
for little ears. It ends with the tag,
"You don't have to be Chris to get
results. You just need his team."
The point of that ad is that, whether you love
or hate Chris Hemsworth, something most of us
can likely agree on is that he clearly has an
excellent team keeping him in shape. That's where
Centr comes in; it's a wellness program Hemsworth
curated that includes a number of experts he's
used over the years to get into the kind of shape
required for the different roles he's taken.
Boxers, gold medal-winning gymnasts, yogis, chefs,
and even podcasting therapists make up the squad.
Hemsworth is currently putting the fruits
of his fitness labors to use to film Thor:
Love and Thunder, the fourth solo
film centered on the God of Thunder.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite workout routines are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.